an effort to boost morale an American
Legion the American Americans leaving
post lining a Georgia Highway with
nearly 300 American flags to show that
American get through this Kovan 19
crisis here to discuss their efforts is
commander of the American Legion Post in
number three three five in Sylvester
Georgia ray Humphrey ray thanks for
being here I'm a member of 225 enforce
Lake Minnesota so a fellow Legionnaire I
preached it thank you for your service
and what you do there talk to Americans
about your effort what you're doing and
why you're doing it well we started off
helping with distributing lunches to
children whenever they were out of
school and our post helped for that and
we were sitting thinking what could we
do besides that do help the situation
and a friend of mine Robert Greer called
me in the middle of the night and told
me he said I think we need to set up the
flags we had been thinking about doing
that anyway we thought about the fact
that during World War two when Pearl
Harbor was bombed blanks came up
everywhere 9/11 flags came up everywhere
so we decided that we were going to get
up that next morning and put flag is up
I put out a call and I got five people
and a and a pound all to come help us
put them up they're staying there now
we've got a sign out in the front of it
this is together we're strong we're
gonna survive this and like Everett
other cases come before us we have
survived it ray I love that sometimes
your friend calling you in the middle of
the night has the best idea sometimes
not but sometimes so and you responded
and I love it what is it about your
veteran military background that gives
you the fortitude in this moment what a
lot of people are anxious or uncertain
well you know yourself when you're under
pressures when you make your best
decisions and you do the best things you
you gonna make you come through we're
gonna make it happen the American Legion
is here for the community we're here for
all the veterans all of our former
warriors we're here to support them and
support everyone in our community we
just want people to know that we're here
we're together we're strong we're going
to survive in a race sometimes that's
what people need just seeing other
people out there displaying their
patriotism on afraid courageous
displaying hope we love what you're
doing they're a post
three three five Ray Humphries thank you
so much for your service and for a shot
in the arm for all of us this morning we
appreciate it
thank you brother never forget you got
it amen
never forget